mélanie joly bonjour merci d'être avec
nous merci ça me fait plaisir mais je
lis votre gouvernement était mis dans
l'embarras cette semaine par la
déclaration de votre collègue emmanuelle
à lumbres en pologne
elle a quitté le comité des langues
officielles jeudi
est-ce que ça clôt les débats font mais
clairement ça ça clôt débats la chambre
des communes je pense que ça a été un
moment difficile à passer pour madame
lambeaux boulot salle après sa décision
que je pense que c'est une sage décision
maintenant on sait au québec on fait
face à un recul du français
ce sont des faits s'est établi des
linguistes ont étudié la question
plusieurs études ont été publiées sur le
point d'être convaincue le slogan de ce
sont des faits on débat beau défi donc
bref je pense maintenant la question
savoir comment on peut travailler à
cesser ce recul là pour qu'au québec on
puisse continuer parlant français encore
pour des générations et qu'on calme
cette anxiété linguistique qui est
toujours présente chez nous et qui
présente aussi j'ai tous les
francophones au pays
on va revenir sur la façon dont vous
allez tenter de calmer cette inquiétude
mais je vais vous attendent sur la crise
cette semaine bon elle a quitté le
comité est ce que j'ai toujours sa place
au caucus le présent elle a sa place au
caucus je pense que pour avoir vécu
moi-même une crise par le passé on
apprend je pense que elle s'est excusée
est là elle a décidé de quitter le
comité et ça fait partie des fois d'un
cheminement politique qui peut être
difficile mais là je pense que le
travail qu'elle doit faire c'est dans
son comté de d'aller chercher l'appui
nécessaire et continuer à être intéressé
par plusieurs sujets mais très
certainement d'apprendre les dynamites
linguistique au québec les propos qu'il
a tenus évidemment vous exposer aux
attaques votre votre gouvernement toute
la semaine il ya des gens il ya des gens
qui ont dit que ça reflétait ces propos
là la pensée de bien des libéraux je l'
ai déjà entendu cette accusation là
surtout à l'endroit de vos collègues
hors québec
qu'est ce que vous en dites moi je pense
qu'il ya une évolution dans tout ce qui
est à la question linguistique au pays
et en tant que ministre qui s'occupe du
dossier des langues officielles depuis
maintenant cinq ans
j'ai eu énormément d'appuis par le
cabinet par le premier ministre et
jamais on ne fait autant en matière de
droits linguistiques
mais peu à peu ce que je me suis rendu
compte en étant en charge du dossier
c'est que clairement il ya un enjeu au
niveau de la langue française et que
pour être en mesure d'avoir une réelle
égalité entre la langue française et la
langue anglaise au pays
on doit être en mesure d'en faire plus
pour le français parce que on doit
reconnaître que c'est une langue
minoritaire et pour la première fois de
notre histoire en tant qu' en tant que
pays on reconnaît que le français qui
est parlé par 8 millions de québécois et
de francophones au pays doit avoir droit
à une nouvelle protection une protection
plus grands je pense aussi que il ya des
nouvelles menaces les menaces
c'est honteux elles sont en lien avec le
fait que par exemple nos enfants qui
sont très connectés sur le web
mais en fait ils sont dans un univers
anglophones en grande partie où le
contenu est beaucoup en anglais où il ya
il ya énormément de deux plateformes en
elles-mêmes sont américaines et
anglophones donc on doit reconnaître
qu'il ya du travail à faire pour assurer
une forme de protection du français sur
le web comment on est capable aussi
alors qu'on attire énormément
d'immigrants pour qu'ils viennent
s'établir et au pays qu'on assure où
c'est un poids démographique aux
francophones dans le contexte d'une
politique d'immigration
ça passe par une réforme de la loi sur
les langues officielles
sa grâce par une réforme de la loi mais
je vous dirais que plus que sa meilleure
ça mais c'est ce que vous vous vous avez
promis une réforme oui modèle de la loi
sur les langues officielles mais aussi
de façon générale la politique de
langues officielles au pays parce que la
loi c'est une chose mais je pense que de
façon générale il ya plusieurs choses
il ya plusieurs autres lois qui ont des
répercussions en matière de langues
officielles mais qui ne sont pas visés
présentement par la politique de l'amp
commencions par la loi parce que c'est
ce que vous avez dans votre programme
électoral c'est ce qu'ils avaient promis
c'est ce qu'on évoque un discours du
trône une idée d où cette loi mais on
travaille extrêmement fort là-dessus
mais je pense que on doit bien faire les
choses et mon objectif c'est de déposer
une réforme le plus rapidement possible
dans le plus rapidement possible mais
avait monsieur thibault si ça prend un
mois de plus pour bien faire les choses
à apprendre un mois de plus pour les
consommateurs disent on voudrait quelque
chose si la fin de la distance maurienne
je pense que j'aimerais bien je vais
tout faire pour que ce soit le cas mais
si ça prend moins que ça soit bon ça
fait un mois que c'est quoi ces janvier
2021 s'est fait l'objet connais moi une
idée dans l'échéancier dans votre tête
c'est quoi mon échéance et vous savez
moi j'ai toujours un sentiment d'urgence
dans la vie donc je suis très impatiente
mais en même temps il faut que cette
réforme là lorsqu'elle est déposée
qu'elle ait l'appui des francophones au
québec qu elle l appui des francophones
hors québec
quelle est la plus des des minorités
linguistiques au pays et des anglophones
deux éléments sur lesquels je voudrais
vous entendre justement concernant
québécois cette semaine qui disait on
devrait donner au québec le pouvoir de
sélectionner les immigrants en fonction
du fait qu'il parle français vous êtes
d'accord avec kid ya un accord québec
canada québec c'est sur les migrations
sepa sur faire une catégorie du meilleur
de la classe sauvage élections et
lorsque en 88 le tout a été développé
l'objectif d'être en sorte de donner
énormément de flexibilité et une très
grande juridiction gouvernement du
québec le gouvernement du québec
od des obligations à respecter en
matière d'intégration de la france 2 des
immigrants pour que ça se passe en
français mais c'est un défi et c'est le
plus grand défi présentement devant
demande québec
moi ça me ferait plaisir de travailler
avec la milice giro pour qu'on puisse
trouver des solutions pour est large et
aussi la question de l'immigration en
france elle à l'aide à la francisation
qu'elle se fasse oui pour les migrants
économiques mais aussi pour les
demandeurs donc l'idée pour vous c'est
davantage sur la francisation des gens
qui arrivent et non pas sur la sélection
de gens qui parlent déjà france la
sélection se fait déjà via nos
politiques d'accueil parce que
l'objectif c'est qu'on a un oeil attirer
les meilleurs immigrants à travers le
monde avec les meilleurs
les commandes totales et les meilleures
connaissances les meilleurs talents
c'est pour ça que c'est un succès à
notre immigration mais ya des défis au
niveau de l'intégration des immigrants
on le sait la francisation québec elle
se fait très bien
via les enfants parce qu'ils vont dans
un système d'éducation en français
lorsqu'ils arrivent mais leurs parents
doivent avoir aussi accès à des formes
de francisation
mais je pense qu'il peut avoir une
collaboration encore plus l'autre
élément sur lequel je vais vous entende
la loi sert fédéral est d'accord pour ou
contre mais la question c'est vraiment
le gouvernement du québec travaille sur
la question angoissante
j'ai décolleté bonne conversation avec
mon collectivement janin barrette
nous on va travailler sur nos preuves
notre propre juridiction et c'est pour
ça que c'est si important de reconnaître
qu'à une particularité pour le québec et
le québec le donc vous allez l'accepter
on aura des bonnes conversations
je sais que mon collègue travaille là
dessus et on doit toujours le faire dans
le respect des droits de chacun mais je
pense que ça vaut la peine de continuer
la conversation mais là je lis merci
beaucoup c'est un fait plaisir